Thank you very much.
So, I'm going to try to talk about a few things
I've been working with for the last two years
and that I think haven't really gotten the
attention specifically from the web developer
community just yet that they deserve, I'm
going to do this in a unique way, I want to
create buzz, how do you create buzz about
technology and how do you do that well.
I have a solution , I have a stage, you as
an audience and I really appreciate your participation
in this a little bit, just being an audience,
we are going to try this, you might want to
mute the microphone a little bit.
Just hold on.
All right.
I know beard and stuff doesn't work so well,
but we're going to see, we're going to see.
Right.
So, waiting for this moment about two and
a half years now since the initial introduction
of it.
Every once in a lifetime, like technology
comes around that changes everything -
clearly into the clicker, I've already given
up.
1944, The Telegraph, it was the first time
that we as people could communicate over distance,
in real time.
It didn't only change communication, it invented
distributed communication in the first place.
The telephone, suddenly it was possible to
communicate with emotions and express urgency
over a phone call, all across the city.
That's never been done before and it's still
the way how we communicate all over the world
today.
Now, today, I'm going to introduce to you
three technologies of this magnitude - .
Number one, a light speed media streaming
service.
Number two, a revolutionary way to make calls.
Number three, a breakthrough internet communications
technology.
A streaming service.
A way to make calls.
An internet communications technology.
A streaming service.
, A way to make calls.
Are you getting it!?
These are not three separate technologies,
this is one technology -- we are calling it
iRTC.
.
Today, we collectively, as web community,
reinvent real time communications.
I call it the year of the peer-to-peer web.
2015.
So who his this guy, that's me, a web developer
forever, lived indeed sin poor for last five
years, organise conferences and help developers
with Web RTC for quite a while, two years,
this is what it is, a set of JavaScript APIs
in the browser to enable peer-to-peer real
time media and data exchange.
Specifically these there are APIs I'm talking
about, it's pretty technical, what powerful
about this, it's an open web standard, if
HTML, JavaScript and CSS have taught us anything,
it's really sticky, a lot of people chip in
and use them, they are you see to learn and
all over the place, we are seeing the same
thing with web TC, the adoption is off the
chart.
Let's start with the internet communication
part.
This is maybe a little bit repetitive for
everybody that knows peer-to-peer already,
how web communication usually works, you send
a message to some kind of server farm somewhere,
it's pushed to another peer that receives
it.
With peer-to-peer that all changes, suddenly
this is how it looks, you can int connect
directly from one browser to another browser,
send data without going through a server.
Now, that's not entirely true as we find out,
you can do with Web RTC without a server,
it's about manual, there is still a server
that's really handy to come into facilitate
two peers to another, like when two people
know a third guy and you ask for an introduction.
Peer A and B here, are a known party and then
do something audiology ice, a candidate exchange
to exchange IP addresses and port, so they
can connect to each other and transfer data.
Now, this is great because the direct connection
is by the default, by the design of the IP
protocol the shortest route they can find
thorough the internet, shortest, the lowest
latency route that they find.
It's great, you know low latency in your connection,
it was essentially invented for audio video
calling, conferencing, light presentations,
file transfer, or even sync music streaming
we have seen, we saw earlier in the cool demo
with the Create Audio in the web browser and
they do it collaboratively.
It's also really good to create resilient
decentralised mesh networks, where you don't
need this bottleneck or point of failure of
the server.
So you can create mesh networks for sensor
data, where sensors collectively create a
network to exchange data or file and content
distribution.
There are also a few things I've learned that
you don't want to use Web RTC for, really
not made for it, it's build usually on RDP,
you don't really know if your message arrived,
it is a bit, unhandy in a lot of cases, for
example, you too traditional music or video
streaming it's not great to use Web RTC, Web
RTC prior ties the low latency part over the
quality part, so you would watch a movie and
suddenly the quality would go down the bandwidth
was reduced a little bit, the traditional
options are better, use a buffer to give the
best quality over latency, synchronised communication,
a chat, is usually something you don't necessarily
want to do on Web RTC unless you want to make
it really private and secure, but most chats
require the other party not to be online that
same time, so it's an async communication,
you don't expect the other person to be in
the same app at the same time and you want
to go through a server that actually pushes
the message to the other party.
In gaming I've seen some people trying to
build multiplayer games on Web RTC, it's not
great, you end up having a different connection
to ever other party, a different latency,
meaning that different events arrive at different
players at different times, that brings the
whole logic of the game and confuses it, so
better use a server and create a single event
that puts everything in order.
Now, the second part, this is what WebRTC
was created for, audio and video calling,
it's really, really powerful and we should
use it more.
To show how it was done so far, this is largely
how we communicate with voice on the internet
these days, we type in a phone number we read
on a website or chat, we exchange user names,
this what we do all day, or use Gmail hang
outs where you need an account and this is
the website of Gmail.
Now, Web RTC changes this theme, because Web
RTC is a real time communication as a feature
in any app or website, you don't need a separate
software any more that facilitates that you
swap to, to be able to communicate with somebody
else, but what you too, you use communication
wherever you are in the context of dealing
with person already.
You don't need to pull out your phone any
more, you can swap devices, so in a way
Web RTC enables embedded and contextual communication,
I've given some examples here that I would
like to see or have already been done, that
for example, you can call your host on, via
Web RTC, both sides have the app, so why not
use the data channel, sorry the data connection
of your phone to facilitate the call instead
of incurring roaming charges on my side, the
came with Gruber, where my driver gets stuck
somewhere where he can't call me in another
country, he doesn't want to call an international
number, telehealth, restaurant booking, property
agents, where you can facilitate a conversion
metric, most companies want to measure if
there was a communication happening between
the interested party and the agent, now they
can measure with Web RTC how long it was,
instead of just seeing if they clicked on
a field to unyield a phone number.
Every market place, eBay, carousel, Singapore
start up, where you want to check up on a
item or too a video call with a seller before
you buy, it in those cases you can use Web
RTC.
Now, looking back at this, we want to get
a little bit in the technology and the features
and how it works, the terminology, the introduction
service is something you would need to write
on the service side, you have a client side
component that communicates with the sir server,
they know a common language to facilitate
the introduction.
You don't need to do this any more these days,
their signalling services out there that do
this for you, so you can just use one of the
STKs, or their server or even library that
you install on your server, to facilitate
this.
That's, that's much easier than writing it
yourself.
Now, there are more hosted services that help
you specifically for the media calling part
in situations where the network might not
necessarily allow for peer connection to be
established, specifically in those cases where
fire-wall prevents it from happening to poke
through a hole into the corporate network
for example.
In those cases they are hosted services that
provide turn, turn services, that essentially
you as a peer connect to, so that the turn
server becomes your peer side of the communication.
So it, in other words, represents you as a
peer with a direct connection to your device
cannot be established, for example, fire-wall
constraints.
More sophisticated service that is very good
in the specific use case of multiparty audio
video umm...
what it does, it increases performance on
the peer side, so if you see this mesh network
up here, think of every peer sending a video
stream to everybody else and receiving a video
stream from everybody else, it has to encrypt
and encode and descript and decode, six streams
if you count the errors on each peer, six
streams.
Now with the introduction of the so-called
MCU, multicast unit of selective forwarding
university, you introduce a server the latency
goes up in favour of the CPU and bandwidth
requirements on the band side, now the errors
are just five, it's one less, everybody sends
just one video out and gets four videos back.
Now, this number goes like the failings of
this method go up obviously the more peers
you add to this communication, so this is
a really valuable service for multiparty it's
available as hosted services you can actually
just book through different providers.
SFU relays media streams to reduce the amount
of connections and use on your device multiparty
sessions.
These are some of the providers out there
that have services around Web RTC specifically
for the calling and conferencing case, I work
one myself, it’s in the centre, sky link
IO, with that, we get to the last bit that
is really fantastic about Web RTC, pretty
sophisticated and it can be of much use, specifically
in emerging markets which I care about being
located into Singapore.
Let's look at how that works a little, this
is how typically the CDN delivery works, you
receive a file from the CDN network, sometimes
they have extra locations say at least it's
in closer proximity, you can increase the
download speed if you had Web RTC to the mix
and you download the same content from other
peers that are also downloading it in segments.
It's a concept you might have heard about
before if you have ever town loaded something
via BitTorrent, where you download one movie
or file or music from other people also downloading
it.
So there too that icon called one is a company
called Swarmify, they have a peer CDN approach
embedded JavaScript link to a file on the
CDN if somebody else in proximity is downloading
you will download from those peers as well.
Another one is WebTorrent worked on created
the peer CDN before and web torrent is a fascinating
project it's a essentially bit torrent but
it works as a website in your browser, actually
want to try this after the talk see how good
the network here really is see if we can download
a movie collectively through a web torrent.
Just to point this out there's a situation
in which you might want to use a server side
peer as well where it's not your browser that
is part of the mesh session but it's a server,
that's possible these days too.
There a really cool project called node web
RTC that you can install this way that gives
you the data channel of web RTC at least not
the audio/video part but the data channel
you can code with it in a serve and make it
an automated service.
This is actually the service that web torrent
users as a bridge to interconnect the bit
torrent network and the WebTorrent network
because they are not comfortably with each
other but through the bridges that are servers
that participate in the WebTorrent session
you can suddenly in put a magnet link in the
start downloading the torrent in your browser.
Why is it the year of web RTC, why is 2015
suddenly everything changed us what new?
There have been so many annoyances with web
RTC if you start looking into it you find
out that Chrome, Firefox don't support it,
subtle differences in, there key protocol
and other things, video Codex, and that it's
not really supported in Safari, mainly the
major annoyance.
Now there’s some good news, last week came
out that Edge is essentially starting to ship
web RTC, not entirely true, when I was talking
about iRTC the vowel was almost right they
do RTC another slightly different interface
on the same use cases still does the same
thing audio/video realtime communication,
slightly different to use, bit more powerful
than what web RTC has offered so far, but
if you look through all the looks and how
Google essentially the creator and driving
force behind web RTC reacted to it, they said
both standards will eventually consortia verge
and be comfortable
with each other.
That's starts essentially from the beginning
where they are lot of efforts being put to
create an adaptor library that makes or RTC
usable the same way you use web RTC.
By using the library you code web RTC and
it works in Edge.
Now there's another library that I help out
with as well, which does the same thing it's
called adapter.js, its built on Google adaptor
file it goes overall the differences in Firefox
and Chrome and Opera, and now it considers
Edge as well so it does the RTC translation
as well.
Additionally it's really unique, it polyfills
web RTC in Safari and Internet Explorer down
to version IE9.
How does it do that if a consumer visits a
website that users adaptor.js and wants to
access web RTC it will offer to install a
little free plug-in, doesn't require browser
restart, just are you fresh of the website,
suddenly web RTC works Safari and IE.
Which opens it up to enterprise use.
Now in mobile web RTC works in these 3 browsers
as well you can use it on your Android phone
you can try it out.
It's remaining it works with Safari and iOS,
I might have some news year the company I
work for kicked off earlier this year a project
called web RTC and Webkit.
We have made some progress, since July Webkit
includes part of the web RTC spec, specifically
the get news media part of it where you get
access to your microphone and camera, and
Apple as accepted that code into Webkit.
The problem is we don't no when Apple ships
anything they don't make this public, could
be as soon as with iOS 9.1, and whatever the
next version or up-grade they ship with it
suddenly the microphone access it available,
sadly the data parts are not yet in Webkit
so I guess in this case it's still another
year so long you have to use the plug-in or
and this more news, if you have seen the web
RTC talk that Google gave the other day one
of there most requested features was that
for Chrome and iOS that people asked to have
web RTC patched on to web view in iOS, and
if Chrome could do that, and so I think they
are now in iteration 2 of testing this out,
so maybe soon Chrome on iOS might actually
support web RTC.
There are plenty of objectives in FTC that
works for web native apps, suddenly everybody
wants in not just a browser thing anymore,
web RTC works in native apps on android, iOS
it's suddenly everywhere.
One more thing that we added with my company
in Singapore, which is screen sharing on HTTPS
in all 4 major browsers, in IE and Safari
it's driven by the free plug-in in Chrome,
Firefox it works out of the box, in Skylink
it's one line it's Skylink.sharescreen it
works in 4 browsers.
Here's the URL again to use the adaptor.js.
Now, I think this is the main take away from
this talk, this year web RTC is finally ready
to be used it can be used in Enterprise, works
in all major browsers without destroying the
user experience too much, yes in some you
need to install a plug-in but it's a rather
straightforward process, that every user get.
We're shipping plenty of updates to those
2.
I can't wait to see what developers that want
to tinker come up with, seen the presentation
earlier on it's just a little glimpse in what's
possible and maybe there are so many more
things I have not thought about yet that you
can do with web RTC in which case it might
be really, really enjoyable.
So go out there and build a lot of things,
use all these platforms and tools out there,
a lot of them are free or really affordable
so you can start
tinkering for very little money and use it
without coding too much stuff.
I am sure you have at some point seen all
these demos about how to build a conference
in your browser in 50 lines of code, and if
I seem to have a bit more time so I might
actually be able to show you some of this
stuff.
I heard yesterday at reject.js there was somebody
demoing a bit of it, now I want to show you
that it can work with a little open source
project that we have.
This is called Get a Room, I thought it was
a nice way to call an online calling solution.
It's open source it's based on React, so what
I am going to do here I am going to use the
native act we have on iOS I'm going to use
Safari over here.
Just to show that actually works.
How do we call this...
JSConfEU... not anything else.
Right.
I want to type in the correct address...
JSConfEU.
Let's see.
There we go.
Oh I look good, doesn't look too bad actually,
I could get used to this.
this is on iOS, if you
have an Android phone just open a browser
join the same URL you will show up here, it
supports up to 4 people, say hi and wave on
screen if you like there we go.
That's how the works.
It works even great on 4G I do this demo in
Singapore on 4G all the time, now it just
goes to wi-fi router and back, finds the shortest
route.
So that's kind of fun.
Now we have a lot more cool demos, let me
show you some others.
We had a talk from the Amazon guys about web
components earlier I thought well, maybe web
component might be the way to get people to
use web RTC, what about just one HTML tag
and suddenly you have an audio/video realtime
chat tool embedded in your website.
Well with web components you can kind of do
this stuff I hope you can see it we have the
little Skylink call tag here that takes parameters,
call ID and caller ID to identify different
peers, maybe let's do a little demo here.
So if we make one person Alice and the other
person we make Bob, you can see it's as sophisticated
as hell.
So from the source code this literally just
including polymer as a library to polyfill
the web components then you have this, oh
it's already open, here's that one HTML tag,
maybe I can show you.
This is essentially just it.
You can put as many as you want on one website.
If I click call Bob here what will happen.
Ooh Alice is calling, pick up, sure.
Suddenly we're in an audio/video communication.
Now another cool thing I really love about
web RTC if you have ever worked with React,
React is kind of awesome it has the state
full UI rendering engine if you have a state
that represents how your website currently
looks like, and you have a tool that allows
you to translate this low latency really fast
to another participant, well what can you
do with it?
So I have this little website here, it's a
really simple website like all it does whenever
I type in here it's just rendered in Markdown
in a dif, on the right side if I open a new
website on the new tab what it will do is
mix in for React you add 2 lines of code to
a React component, one includes the mix in,
one is my API key, it starts syncing the state
between both browsers, it sent the object
from this component in real time to the other
browser which then renders the exact same
site if your entire website is written in
react you can do screen sharing without pixel
data.
That renders the exact same thing it's
based on something that one of the creators
of React did originally I thought it was kind
of cool tool with 2 lines of code.
So many more demos from like chat room, simple
chat rooms you can use to selfie demo, that's
really popular in Asia for some reason where
you can load a camera website on your Android
phone.
If you do selfies with a selfie stick you
can't really reach the button you need another
way to trigger the photo, you can do this
by loading on another Android phone or laptop,
like a retrieval website where
you can then see a preview from your phone
via webRTC you can trigger the photo from
there, it actually sends in full resolution
from the phone via data channel to the other
device so that's open source, you can try
this out here.
We have a little collaboration tool where
you can see how co-working could work if you
actually see an updated picture every 5 seconds,
a lot of good stuff to play round with.
I think I am slowly running out of time anyway
so let's do one last thing to see if we can
make this wi-fi go down.
Sorry in advance if it works.
So this is the cool project that we have been
working on, if you go to the same website
you will start streaming that same movie that
I am streaming now, and on the left side it
renders a graph of who am I downloading this
movie from right now.
I'm clearly loading it from the server the
more people that join the website in your
Chrome or Firefox browser, the more people
will show up and the more people will start
downloading segments of that movie, you can
get from everybody else, it's currently on
the same website and it just happens in your
browser, it's kind of really cool.
With that, thank you very much and I hope
you enjoy tinkering with Web RTC.
.